ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Welcome to the
Google Chrome Developers'
WebGL Hangout.
And today, we've got a bunch
of people from the Web GL
community who are
participating.
A bunch of people from the 3JS
side, and we've got Brendan
Kenny, who's on the Google
Maps GL Team,
Brandon Jones from the--
well, he's done some cool
demos, tojico.com.
So if you guys would like to
give us a nice, small self
introduction.
I'll start.
OK, so I'm Ilmari Heikkinen,
and I work on the Google
Chrome Developer Relations
team here at London.
And basically, I do demos,
articles, talks, stuff, and
run hangouts like this.
So please?
PAUL LEWIS: I'll go next.
I'm Paul Lewis.
Some people know me from
aerotwist.com, I spent most of
my days as a web developer.
But outside of that, I do web
GL demos and kind of make
myself useful in that way,
writing tutorials and that
kind of thing.
JEROME ETIENNE: OK,
so I go next.
Hello, Ricardo.
So I've been doing
some tutorials on
learningthreejs.com, and some
nice demo and [? currently ?]
I'm writing J Query.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: All
right, so that
person was Jerome Etienne.
I think he missed that.
JEROME ETIENNE: Sorry.
Yes.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN:
Can't hear you.
BRENDAN KENNY: There we go.
Hi, I'm Brendan Kenny.
As Ilmari said, I work
on the Maps Developer
Relations Team at Google.
So like him, I write demos
and code samples and help
developers make good maps.
And we're kind of gearing up
right now, actually, with some
really exciting WebGL data
visualization stuff that we
started talking about last week
at Strata and this week
at South by Southwest
in a couple weeks.
Which is great, because WebGL is
very close to my heart, and
any excuse I have to make it as
much of my job as possible
is very welcome.
BRANDON JONES: I'm Brandon
Jones, and I'm a HTML5
developer for Motorola, Web GL
hobbyist, it doesn't actually
have too much to do with my
real job, unfortunately.
But I just like to put several
demos online, author of the GL
Matrix Library, and just
generally enjoy working with
and promoting WebGL
wherever I can.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: And we have
Ricardo joining us as well.
RICARDO CABELLO: Hello.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Can you give
us a short introduction?
RICARDO CABELLO: Sure.
Can you hear me?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Yes.
RICARDO CABELLO: Cool.
So I'm Ricard Cabello, or
Cabe-ye-lo, and I started a
library for doing
3D in JavaScript
about two years ago.
Originally, it was for cameras,
and now we have a
WebGL renderer and we have
some samples with that.
And I mainly work on that
library nowadays.
PAUL LEWIS: I think
I've heard of it.
Complete mystery [INAUDIBLE].
RICARDO CABELLO: Yeah, I keep
trying to do nice things so
you can see it.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: That is
Ricardo Cabello, or Mr. Doob,
from the 3JS fame.
RICARDO CABELLO: I didn't
mention the name?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: No.
RICARDO CABELLO: Well, you just
you get an idea how good
I am at those things.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: OK, so the
agenda today is, well, we've
got a lot of 3JS people here, so
let's talk about 3JS, let's
talk about WebGL, what works,
what doesn't, how to get
started, that kind of thing.
If you're working on anything
cool that you can share, it
might be fun to hear about it.
So thank you all
for joining us.
This is great.
RICARDO CABELLO: Is there a way
to know how many people
are watching this?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN:
I have no idea.
I don't think so.
We can see a recorded
views on YouTube.
PETE: Hey guys, I'm Pete.
I'm one of the developer
advocates working on the
Chrome Team with Ilmari and a
bunch of these other guys.
Let me actually ask a first
question from one of the
things that I've seen a
bunch of people ask.
What's the best way for
folks to get started
with the 3JS libraries?
RICARDO CABELLO: I think
Jerome can answer that.
JEROME ETIENNE: Well, OK.
So there's a bunch of tutorials
available on the network.
I'm awfully be sorry,
I'm bad with names.
So probably with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
which is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And it's called Get Started,
if I remember well?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, getting
started with 3JS.
Definitely.
Yeah, that's what it's called.
Sort of does what it says on
the tin, that one, really.
JEROME ETIENNE: So it's under
[? Read Me ?] and I think you
know HTML5 rocks, too.
And personally, I do learning
through GS blog which is a
bunch of tutorial on that.
If you want to learn
learnings 3JS.
Obviously, readings and tutorial
is a good part of it.
After that, you can come and
join the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
channel to get some
help, live help.
You can [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
or in fact, the meat of 3JS
is inside the example.
There is something like Ricardo
maybe can correct me,
but a huge bunch of them
is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
RICARDO CABELLO: 1,000.
JEROME ETIENNE: 1,000.
I hope not for you.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a good bunch of them, showing
the values possibility.
You read the code, and after
that, you get how it works.
It's not that hard.
Essentially, it's pretty easy,
I believe, at least.
RICARDO CABELLO: I think it's
always the best way just to
play with examples and choose
some values, until you start
to get an idea more or less
how the API works.
And these days, I am working on
the documentation finally,
so that will hopefully make
things easier for people that
don't think like me.
BRANDON JONES: If I could just
add something to that.
I think at the last WebGL camp
that we did at Mozilla, Henric
mentioned that anything that
we're doing with WebGL is
effectively open source by
default, because you can go to
any of the sample pages and hit
Control U, whatever it is
in your browser of choice,
and pull up the
source right there.
And I think I've yet to see a
3JS demo that was actually
obfuscated in any way.
So if you see something that you
like online, pull up the
source and start looking
through it.
I've found that that's, in many
cases, the best way to
learn, once you've gotten
over that initial
getting started period.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: I also have
some basics of 3JS slide tech
up with a bunch of examples.
So that might be one way to get
started as well, if you
just want to--
PETE: Where can folks
find those?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Sorry?
PETE: Where can people
find those if they
want to look for them?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: OK, so
the 3JS home page--
actually the 3JS wiki has links
for getting started.
I think it's
github.com/mrdoob/three.js and
click on the wiki-link there.
PETE: And your slides?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: My
slides would be at
fhtr.org/basicsof3js with
strange capital--
PETE: Yes, it sounds
like a great URL.
What we'll do is we'll add the
links that get mentioned in
the video, as well as in the
comments for the video
afterwards.
So if you miss any of these
links, don't worry
about that too much.
BRANDON JONES: If we put
something into the group chat,
will it show up for anybody
who's viewing the broadcast?
PETE: No, sadly, it won't.
RICARDO CABELLO: I wonder if
it's better just for people
that want to start to go to
learning WebGL just so they
see what the complexity of the
things are before going to a
framework or a library.
I don't know what's better, if
it's better to go to a library
first, and then understand
what's going
on, or I don't know.
PAUL LEWIS: I mean, that's
kind of how I started.
I started out with 3JS.
And as I got kind of comfortable
with that, I then
hit a slight frustration wall
where I was like, OK, but how
is this actually doing all
this magic on screen?
So for me, I mean, not
necessarily the same for
everybody, but I think my
experience was definitely that
if I went straight to the
WebGL, I found it
overwhelming, I think.
Having it abstracted away so I
could learn the basic concepts
was helpful first, like
[INAUDIBLE] geometry, all
those things.
And then after that, I started
to try and understand what was
going on underneath it.
But I can see the other way
around as well, and I think a
lot of people would say
it works for them
the other way around.
But certainly, in my case, I
found it easier to start with
the library first and then
understand what it was doing
once I understood
those basics.
PETE: Did anybody else go
the other way around?
BRANDON JONES: I went the other
way around, but I think
I was a bit of a special case in
that I'd been working with
3D APIs direct to 3D and OpenGL
on the desktop for a
while, just as hobby.
And so jumping into WebGL
initially was a fairly natural
transition, because
it really is just
OpenGL ES 2 on the web.
And so if you've got that kind
of background, it's probably
going to be more natural and
easier just to jump into using
the API directly.
But if you're not familiar with
that, I mean, it's an API
that's evolved over
a good long time,
and it's fairly complex.
There's a lot of moving parts.
And it takes a lot of
boilerplate code just to get
that initial polygon on screen,
during which you're
pulling your hair out going,
why can't I see anything?
As such, I'm always in favor
of people learning what's
going on behind the scenes.
But I really do think for
something like this, starting
out with a framework is maybe
the path of least frustration.
That said, I do wish that there
was a little bit more in
the way of a bridge between your
3JSes and the raw WebGL.
To say, all right, well if
you're doing this in the
framework, here's how you
transition into the real world
when you want to do something
that's not nicely encapsulated
by a library, because
everybody's going to hit that
at some point.
JEROME ETIENNE: Yeah, but
it's always [INAUDIBLE].
My opinion, at least, is what
bigger [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of 3JS or [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is you don't need to
understand all
the mathematics behind.
BRANDON JONES: Which is a huge
plus at the very beginning
when you're starting to learn,
because that's very
complicated stuff.
JEROME ETIENNE: People like it
because [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and stuff like that, or they
don't want to do that.
So at least my personal opinion,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] take
advantage of libraries, because
they hide all of these
problems.
BRANDON JONES: I completely
agree.
PAUL LEWIS: I think that's
a really good point.
But I think, Brandon, I think
you touched on this awhile ago
in one of your blog posts about
one of the reasons that
you do the raw WebGL is as much
as anything, sometimes
you can really target exactly
what you want to do.
And the best one in the world
any engine is trying to give
you a fairly generic viewing.
They'll let you do a number of
tasks, and you might need to
just go straight in and
do one specific thing.
And in that case, it
might not be as
suitable to use the library.
It may actually be more suitable
to just try and
pinpoint that one little thing
that you're trying to do.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: [INAUDIBLE]
like?
Since I see a bunch of
tutorials that are--
on one hand, there's 3JS,
getting started with 3JS,
getting started with
libraries.
And then there's this sort of
low level WebGL, the very
basics, and getting
up from there.
So I guess the bridge would be
something that's sort of like
making your own 3D library,
or something like that.
BRANDON JONES: I would have a
really hard time recommending
that to anybody, honestly.
JEROME ETIENNE: [INAUDIBLE]
can do it.
BRANDON JONES: It would
certainly be an educational
experience for people, but
yeah, I don't know.
Doing your own library--
BRENDAN KENNY: Well it depends
on, are you trying to get
something done, or you
just trying to make
something and learn?
I think Paul would be the best
person to ask about how
effective that is at learning.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, so my way of
learning WebGL after spending
some time with 3JS was to
try and write my own.
And Brendan was actually
exceedingly helpful during
that process as I was sort of
scratching my head and pulling
my hair out for sort of, how
do you use matrices.
All those kinds of things that
had been abstracted away, and
I couldn't remember from
my time at school.
Would I use my own engine
in production?
I put my hand on my heart and
say no, I'd use 3JS if I was
in a production setting, because
I think it's a lot
more mature as a library.
In terms of learning, I
learned tons doing it.
I learned what not to do.
There are still tons of things
that I'm still learning that I
should have done better.
But I think in terms of starting
from absolutely no
understanding to understanding
OK, these are the components,
these are the bits that go in,
yeah, I'm glad I tried to
write one, certainly.
So it's valid from a learning
standpoint, for sure.
But as Brendan said, if you're
trying to get something done,
you might want to use something
that's already
mature and out there
and working.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, it won't
be an efficient process.
You'll be spending a lot of time
wondering why nothing is
on the screen.
PETE: So actually, there's a
question on the moderator
right now that I think this
segues really nicely into.
The question is, what are some
of the most popular, efficient
tools and libraries for people
to use with WebGL?
BRANDON JONES: Define
efficiency.
I mean, are you talking about
efficiency of rendering?
Are you talking about efficiency
of how fast it is
to get something up on screen?
There's several different ways
you could take that.
PETE: Yeah, absolutely.
I'll leave that up to your
imagination as the questioner
did for us.
So however you want
to answer that.
JEROME ETIENNE: Go
ahead, guys.
RICARDO CABELLO: Isn't there
like a wiki page with all the
list of WebGL--
I think it's on Chome's website,
there is a list of
all the frameworks
and libraries for
people to play with?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRANDON JONES: I think
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] has something
similar, too.
JEROME ETIENNE: Maybe we can
decompose that and see, for
example, if efficiency is
development time, if
efficiency is running speed,
or I don't know.
We can list by assumption.
BRENDAN KENNY: I haven't used
all of the WebGL framework, so
I haven't used, say, SceneJS
or things like that.
But I'm a big fan of--
I know Brandon was talking
earlier about the transition
between 3JS and then kind
of more pure WebGL.
I'm a big fan of PhiloGL or
Phy-lo GL, depending on how
you pronounce your
Greek letters.
And also, this one doesn't get
talked about much, but Evan
Wallace has made some really
amazing WebGL demos.
He's the guy that made the ball
that's floating in water,
and it does real time refraction
and everything,
path tracing.
Anyway, he has a really
lightweight WebGL library on
his GitHub account, on
his GitHub page.
And I don't know if he ever
advertises it, but you can go
and fork it and use it.
So I'm a big fan of those, but
only if you want to get as
close to WebGL as possible
with taking some of the
boilerplate out of the mix.
RICARDO CABELLO: Have
you tried the TDL
one from Greg Taveres?
BRENDAN KENNY: That's
a good point.
That's another one.
I haven't used that
in awhile, though.
I don't know if he--
RICARDO CABELLO: But
do you know how he
compares to the Evan one?
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, it's
pretty similar.
Greg is like a graphics
programmer, longtime graphics
programmer, so it's
definitely--
and he comes from like
a C, C++ background.
And I think that's he was
writing it while he was still
kind of getting to
know JavaScript.
So it's not as naturally
JavaScript, but it's
definitely in terms of
efficiency, it's definitely
there, because that's why he
wrote it was to get things on
the screen with no
cruft in between.
So yeah, definitely a fan of
picking code from Greg's code
anytime I want to just
get something done.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Brandon,
you've done like the Quake 3
demo, and the JS2 demo, and the
Rage demo, and they all
seem to be something that would
actually use quite a bit
of horsepower and require
a lot of performance.
So do you have any tips
and tricks on that?
BRANDON JONES: Oh goodness.
I'm very fond of saying that
anything you would have done
in the desktop still applies
here, for the most part.
But I'm learning more
and more that--
and I think this is great, by
the way, that we've got a
large community of people who
are coming into WebGL as
experienced web developers,
but not necessarily
experienced 3D developers
for the desktop.
So I think that advice maybe
falls a little flat.
But some of the just really
general tips-- and I've seen
that many of the frameworks
allow these optimizations in
some way, shape or form--
is primarily, you just want to
group as many similar draw
calls together as you can.
So if you've got a whole bunch
of geometry that uses the same
texture, the same material,
whatever the case may be, you
want to try to, as much as
possible, render those in a
single draw call.
I know, for example, like 3JS--
and I don't know the
right terminology
for this, maybe
Ricardo can help me out--
allows you to actually
batch up geometry
into a single buffer.
RICARDO CABELLO: Managing
geometry in just a single
geometry, yeah.
BRANDON JONES: Yeah,
thank you.
That's what it is.
You want to try to
do that kind of
thing as much as possible.
So just as a high level bit of
real world advice, so for the
Quake 3 and the TF2 demos,
what I tend to do is do a
pre-process over the
level, just sort
everything by material.
And then if I'm doing any
visibility culling, it tends
to be on the material level, not
the geometry block level.
And my render loop is basically
just a loop over
every material in the scene,
and then I render every
triangle that uses that material
to switch state as
little as possible.
And this tends to be a very
effective way of rendering a
lot of polygons very quickly.
But it does take a lot
of pre-sorting and
pre-calculating to begin with.
So it's not necessarily an
easy process, but it's a
worthwhile one if you're
really going for high
performance.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Thanks.
That's awesome.
OK, so I'm going to go through
my spiel a bit.
So this is the Google Chrome
Developers WebGL hangout.
And here we have a list of
guests from the WebGL world.
Starting from the left, Brandon
Jones from tojico.com
Then we have Brendan Kenny, from
the Google Maps Developer
Relations Team.
Me, Ilmari Heikknen, from the
Google Chrome Developer
Relations Team.
Then we've got Jerome Etienne,
from learning3js.com.
Paul Lewis from aerotwist.com,
and Ricardo
Cabello of 3JS fame.
And we are talking about
WebGL and 3JS.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Greetings, we have a new guest.
Any questions thus far?
RICARDO CABELLO: I
think he's mute.
MICHAEL ENSMINGER: Now
can you hear me?
Wow.
Hi.
No, I just joined.
I just want to agree on what
Brandon just said, that
keeping draw calls down
is a big one.
I'm sitting with a WebGL
project right now,
prototyping, and we saw some
great performance increase
when we did just that.
We just brought down like 2,000
draw calls into one, it
was this huge performance
increase, which was great.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN:
Cool, thanks.
PETE: I have a question
for Brendan.
Brendan, I know that the Maps
Team is doing some stuff
around WebGL.
Can you talk about that
just a little bit?
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, yeah.
So we've been kind of on
a kick lately to get--
let's see.
Thinking about how to visualize
large data sets,
especially geographic data sets,
but in our case just
large data sets, kind looking at
beyond 3D or I guess games
applications of WebGL.
I'm a gamer at heart, but it's
interesting to look at what
experiences WebGL enables that
didn't exist before,
or even a year ago.
So we've been looking at kind
of what can we do to kind of
take a glimpse into large data
sets and see the kind of
patterns that are there.
And we have a presentation,
but I don't know
how to link it up.
But we've been starting to
present some things with my
colleague Chris Broadfoot,
just presented a
really great data set.
It's like 1 million GPS
coordinates from cabs in San
Francisco from one night
in San Francisco.
And so he visualized
it in real time.
You can kind of see where all
the cabs are, but then you can
kind of also spread it out
through time, so you can start
seeing, where are the slow parts
of the city, where are
cabs just kind of hanging
out during the night?
Or even like we started looking
at some really cool
stuff of kind of the spread
of the GPS points.
Because you can see in downtown
San Francisco,
there's not good GPS reception
because of the tall buildings.
And so you see the GPS becomes
kind of a fog instead of nice
paths on the road.
Once you can actually see it
on screen, you can start
getting ideas for teasing out
patterns and data that you
wouldn't actually be able
to do if you just
saw it in a CSV file.
Anyway, so yeah, we've been
working on kind of good ways
of doing that, and then starting
to advocate to
developers just now.
We're going to continue, there's
a South by Southwest
session sometime very
soon, I'm not sure.
Yeah, so that's kind of
what we're up to.
RICARDO CABELLO: Isn't it next
week, South by Southwest?
BRANDON JONES: It could
be, I don't know.
PETE: I think it starts
this weekend.
BRANDON JONES: I think the
interactive starts this
weekend, and maybe music is
next week or something.
PETE: So there's another
question from the moderator
that I want to just pop up.
And the question was,
do you think that--
and it's OK not to know the
answer to this-- but do you
think that Dart will have some
WebGL functions directly
included in it?
BRANDON JONES: So I was actually
playing around with
WebGL in Dart maybe a week
ago, and just doing some
initial pokings at that.
It is supported right now.
You access it through
their DOM API.
So it's very much just a
direct exposure of the
underlying WebGL API.
There's not anything really too
terribly special about it
to help you out, at
least not yet.
I don't know what their
plans are for it,
going in the future.
And I must say that it's a
little annoying to work with,
because any of your
enumerations, you end up
having to type out the full
WebGL object name every time.
It's like
WebGLRenderContext.Blend,
which is a little annoying.
But it works.
It works quite well.
I found it to be fairly
performant.
And yeah, it's just it's very
low-level at this point.
That's about the only thing
I have to say against it.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, I think
it's hard with WebGL being so
young to really commit to an
abstraction that maybe Dart
would like, and then know in
like a year or two that it
would have been a
good decision.
So it seems like it's better to
leave it at low-level, and
then maybe rely on authors
to make something
like a 3JS in Dart.
Theoretically in time, it might
be nice, the kind of
tight checking and other
benefits of Dart might be a
good thing there.
On the other hand, WebGL code is
already very typed, because
you have to have typed arrays,
and that sort of thing.
It seems like it would be a bit
of a wash, like it's very
much there if you're
using Dart.
But I don't know if there are
any great advantages that Dart
brings there.
BRANDON JONES: I didn't
find it to be any
better or worse, really.
It's just WebGL.
PETE: Cool.
Well, there's another
question in here.
With WebGL coming to mobile
platforms, what kind of new
applications will this enable,
and will performance be good
enough to compete with
native applications?
This is from Jeff.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Well, WebGL
performance is basically
JavaScript performance plus the
bindings of the open GLES
2.0 driver's performance.
So if the mobile JavaScript
performance is there, then you
should be able to do stuff that
you can do on mobile in
native code, graphics-wise.
Well, that's my hunch
at least.
PAUL LEWIS: There was that Opera
demo a week or so ago,
right, that was running 60,
70 frames a second?
And it was the Opera, the guy
walking on the platform
looking really mean
and grumpy.
You know the one?
JEROME ETIENNE: It was 72 FPS
with 37,000 polygons, and it
was on Opera Mobile.
But well, this was a demo.
The main difference that
I have seen on
mobile is two things.
First, it's [? VPU ?]
doesn't have the same
characteristic.
So what we are used to
on desktop, mobile
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
bottleneck [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
almost the same.
Another part which for 3JS is
important, the JavaScript is
much lower.
So all 3JS is going to have to
make progress, let's say.
BRANDON JONES: So just to throw
this out, I actually had
a coworker of mine show me the
new Opera 12 running on, I
think it was an Atrix 2.
And we pulled up my Quake 3
demo, and we were able to get
it running on there at about
26 frames per second, which
was pretty good, overall.
Now as a disclaimer on that one,
I've got the Quake 3 demo
set so that when you run it on
mobile now, it will actually
render at a quarter of the
screen size and then upscale
it through CSS, so it's
not utilizing every
pixel on the screen.
But generally, it still gives
acceptable results, and we
were getting pretty close
to 30 frames per
second on that device.
I also tried it on, I think, an
older model Samsung Galaxy
tab, and unfortunately,
I was getting
maybe 12 or so on that.
But it was also rendering a
much larger screen area.
But I must say that overall, I
was actually very impressed at
how well Opera was able
to handle it.
I've done some similar
experiments in Firefox in the
past, unfortunately haven't done
those recently, but it's
always seemed to do decently.
And I'm looking forward to when
they finally flip the
switch on WebGL for Chrome
on mobile, to see
where that is, too.
But it's definitely much lower
than you would ever get on the
desktop, but performs better
than expected, I'd say.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, you
shouldn't feel bad about
shrinking the back buffer,
because that's common on
native apps, too.
So they can't complain.
I'm really excited about
the mobile WebGL stuff.
I think not only does it let
us make kind of this new
content, so that's exciting
in and of itself,
having it on mobile.
But I think in terms of the
mobile platform itself, it'll
enable kind of experiences that
we haven't been able to
make before, and it will be in
your pocket, just like a
native app.
There are very different
performance characteristics.
You definitely have to think
about the JavaScript execution
and think about how much can
you kind of pre-compute and
pre-transform, or pre- whatever
on the server side
beforehand, so that when it
comes down to JavaScript,
you're not spending a lot of
time decompressing a mesh or
doing some fancy thing, where
it will take 10 seconds and
maybe it'll block the
main thread as it
uploads to the GPU.
Generally, the vertex shaders
on phones are less powerful.
But they do have an advantage of
a lot of them use this kind
of tiled deferred rendering
behind the scenes, which lets
you save a lot on the
fragment shaders.
It won't actually run the
fragment shaders until the
very end, so you don't get
a lot of overdraws.
Sometimes you can do fancier
effects than you
think, which is nice.
I had something else, but
I can't remember it now.
RICARDO CABELLO: There
was something I
was trying last week.
I don't know if we can see it
with the Opera browser for
mobile, but they also allow
access to the webcam.
I don't know if this
works at all.
PETE: There you go, if
you pull it back
just a little bit?
RICARDO CABELLO: Can you see?
Oh, this is my finger.
Sorry.
Try it again.
It's an example from--
I never know how to pronounce
his name.
I think it's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
And he has this webcam toy that
basically, with Opera,
you can access to the webcam
from the website, and then
apply filters using
WebGL and GLSL.
So this guy has like
a ton of effects.
It's like you can start to get
an idea of kind of augmented
reality, whenever something that
actually makes sense to
do with that.
But basically, [INAUDIBLE].
But now, you have access from
the browser to play with that.
Let's see if I can make
it work again.
JEROME ETIENNE: Ricardo,
did you try augmented
reality on the phone?
RICARDO CABELLO: No, no.
I guess this is just--
I guess it's going to be quite
a little bit slow to find
targets and everything, but
let's see if I can make it--
BRENDAN KENNY: Part of the
problem is that framing on
those cameras can be a little
slow, and a lag as well.
So maybe if somebody's trying
to find something, they've
already pointed the opposite
way by the time your
code gets to it.
I remember the other thing I
was going to say was just
definitely check out both Apple
and Google have great
resources on the Android and
IOS development sites for
graphics in native
mobile apps.
And that definitely applies if
you're interested in getting
into mobile WebGL, it's the same
exact thing, kind of the
same performance characteristics
as obviously,
once you upload your GPU,
it's all the same.
But looking at how you can
make your data faster to
compute on, what can you do in
your shaders, that sort of
thing, to get better
mobile code.
Because it is a really is a
pretty different architecture
underneath the API.
But definitely check those
out if you're interested.
RICARDO CABELLO: I was seeing
some people that were kind of
expecting the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
some of the 3.js examples, they
were expecting that the
3.js examples were going to work
on mobile, but I don't
think that's really going
to be the case.
If you wanted [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to mobile, we should start right
from the mobile and then
going out to the desktop, rather
than having desktop,
and then magically working on
the mobile or just playing in
the library, because
it's too slow.
It just needs to be from the
bottom, from the slower to the
fastest one
PETE: So there's a question here
from Andrew in the UK.
Many developers have now gained
familiarity with 2D
context of Canvas.
What resources would you
recommend for transitioning to
3D with WebGL?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN:
From 2D Canvas.
WebGL is a whole different
beast. 2D Canvas is where you
draw stuff, you draw paths,
lines, text, images.
In WebGL, you've got textures
and buffers and shaders that
actually turn all that other
things into an image on your
screen, and that is
a pretty big leap.
But I would go with
learningWebGL.com, which gives
you an understanding of the
very basics, and getting
started with simple things.
The other thing would be 3JS
or another library that
abstracts away all the
complicated things, or rather,
the things that you don't really
actually want to do
most of the time.
BRANDON JONES: I don't know
if it directly maps to the
question that he's asking, but
there was an interesting blog
post by Greg [? Cateras ?]
that's entitled, "WebGL
Fundamentals: WebGL is a 2D
API." And that's an interesting
read at the very
least, in that he just goes
over basically how WebGL
functionality maps to
just 2D drawing.
And in the end actually, it
really truly is a 2D API.
It's the matrices
that make it 3D.
So if you're familiar with a
lot of 2D concepts, that's
probably a decent article to
read through, because it does
hit on some of those concepts.
JEROME ETIENNE: OK, just I don't
know if you can see, but
OpenGL ES Programming Guide,
just like the reference to
learn OpenGL.
People may not know, but WebGL
is basically the exact same as
this, with JavaScript
on the side.
So if you want to understand
actually WebGL, you read that
and you make a lot
of progress.
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PETE: Are there actually any
books available today
specifically on WebGL or
anything like that, if
somebody wants to get a book
that anyone would recommend?
BRENDAN KENNY: Not yet.
One is coming, but not for
a while, later this year.
So I think right now, that
really is the book.
BRANDON JONES: What's
the one that you're
thinking that's coming?
BRENDAN KENNY: Are you
talking to me?
RICARDO CABELLO: Your book.
BRENDAN KENNY: It might be
yours, I'm not sure.
BRANDON JONES: That's
what I'm wondering.
BRENDAN KENNY: I'm not writing
a secret book,
I'm not saying that.
PAUL LEWIS: There's a book
coming, said [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JEROME ETIENNE: That's
not mine, I promise.
BRANDON JONES: Yeah, I've been
coauthoring a WebGL beginner's
guide, but I really have no
idea when it's going to be
coming out.
I can say that the first drafts
of all the chapters are
done, but that doesn't mean
too much in terms of
publishing dates.
BRENDAN KENNY: So you're going
to finish it like next week,
is what you're saying?
[INAUDIBLE]
right now, on the air.
Wow.
BRANDON JONES: No.
PAUL LEWIS: That's a
big commencement.
Well done, Brandon.
PETE: And it is recorded
live and will be--
BRANDON JONES: No, erase
everything that I just said.
JEROME ETIENNE: You're
committed.
No re-do.
BRENDAN KENNY: Anyway, it will
be nice to have an actually
WebGL book.
Because I know it is difficult,
talking to some
people that have opened up the
OpenGL ES 2 Programming Guide,
and it's like C Code.
OpenGL is already rather
esoteric too.
It's kind of legacy, 20
year plus legacy.
So it will be nice to have a
book that's specifically about
WebGL, so you're not
simultaneously learning about
OpenGL and trying to translate
in your head
the JavaScript calls.
But it maps fairly closely.
So once you kind of are a little
more used to WebGL,
it's definitely a very
handy guide.
I keep it on my desk
for reference.
RICARDO CABELLO: [INAUDIBLE]
maybe about GLSL rather
than WebGL?
Like WebGL is was kind of the
connection between say
JavaScript and GLSL.
They're shading language.
And probably the shading
language is something that you
can use for doing much more
different stuff, and not the,
say, boring stuff.
It's in the middle.
So I don't have the book in my
hand but there are really good
books about GLSL that you get
an idea of how the graphics
cards work.
And what you send to the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and you start to understand
more how
the pieces fit together.
PETE: Could you just define what
GLSL is for maybe those
of us who are a little
bit naive?
RICARDO CABELLO: Wow, anyone
want to do that?
PETE: Or like the 10 second
version of it?
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: GLSL
is the Graphics
Library Shading Language.
PETE: All right, there we go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Now
everything's clear, right?
PETE: As mud, absolutely.
BRENDAN KENNY: It's a very small
language that is very
domain specific to graphics,
and it has some nice things
that are built in like vectors,
or native types.
So that it's easy to express
kind of what's efficient on
the graphics card in this
language, and that's what you
actually pass up to
the graphics card.
The driver compiles it to code
while your program is running,
while your JavaScript
app is running.
And then that's what's run
on the graphics card.
So it can be very efficient,
these little programs run on
the graphics card.
So when you pass the data, these
little programs run on
that data and decide what
shows up on the screen.
And the nice thing about it is
that it's the same language
that's used pretty much for all
of OpenGL, but definitely
for OpenGL ES.
So there's nothing, there's
no translation to
JavaScript or anything.
It's the exact same language.
And it's also so small that
you really can look.
I just have the spec, I don't
even refer to anything else
anymore, because there's so
few features that you can
learn it all and fit
it in your head.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEROME ETIENNE: Go
ahead, Ilmari.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Yeah, so
GLSL, the one-line pithy
description that I have is that
it's like C for graphics.
BRENDAN KENNY: But it's not
C for graphics like CG,
it's the other one.
PETE: Cool, I just want to
make one quick comment.
If you're watching this live
right now and you have
questions for any of these guys,
make sure you post them
to the Moderator link, which
is listed there in the
comments, so that we can
get to your questions.
I'll pass it back
over to Ilmari.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: OK so
yes, welcome back.
This is the Google Chrome
Developers WebGL hangout, and
with me today I have guests,
Brandon Jones from tojico.com
Brendan Kenny from the
Maps Team at Google.
I'm on the Chrome Developer
Relations Team.
Then we have Jerome
Etienne, who is
currently somewhere else.
He was hiding.
OK, Michael Ensminger,
do you want to do an
introduction, actually?
MICHAEL ENSMINGER: Yeah, sure.
I was part of the teams that
worked in Rome for example,
and I'm a freelance, and I do
some WebGL development.
I'm also doing this little open
source project called
Glow, which is like a WebGL
wrapper, if you like GS play
with shaders really quickly.
Hopefully, I'm starting a big
WebGL project next Tuesday,
which is due to be out in the
end of April, I think.
Fingers crossed.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Awesome.
Then we have Paul Lewis, from
aerotwist.com, and Ricardo
Cabello, of 3JS fame,
and also from Rome.
So the topic today is WebGL,
3JS, the meaning of life,
which we haven't gotten around
to yet, but that is fixable.
Actually, I have a question.
What kind of a content pipeline
do you guys use?
Like if you have a model in Maya
or some other 3D software
and you want to do it on the web
page, you want to put it
on the web page, how
do you do that?
Are there any easy solutions?
MICHAEL ENSMINGER: Can I say?
I think to Bartek, whatever
his last name is, he did a
little unity exporter, which I
really like, and I use a lot.
Because then you go
through that.
It can import from any 3D
package, which is nice.
And what's is really nice is
what I've used a lot, that you
can do small C Sharp plug-ins to
tag objects and do your own
materials and whatnot,
and customize or
export it real easy.
So I'm really a big fan of
that pipeline, basically.
BRANDON JONES: I'll
second that.
I've actually been working on
a set of Unity exporters and
whatnot, a lot of it based
on what Bartek was doing.
I was slightly frustrated in
that Unity doesn't actually
expose APIs for querying
things like visibility
information or whatnot.
So if you want to use it to
expose full, like game
appropriate levels, it's going
to take a little bit more work
on your part.
But it does definitely give
you a very good, low-level
access to your basic meshes,
animations, materials,
anything like that.
And so as a general
asset exporter, it
works really well.
RICARDO CABELLO: That's a full,
open source net, I will
say, blender.
BRANDON JONES: Wait,
why do we all laugh
when he says blender?
I mean, come on, it's
a good tool.
BRENDAN KENNY: You people are
terrible, don't laugh.
MICHAEL ENSMINGER: Me and
Ricardo have had this
discussion 100 times.
Blender is very good.
Blender is a very good
tool, of course.
RICARDO CABELLO: Yeah, you
can just write any other
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] pattern and
then you actually have access
to a lot of stuff.
We have it for exporting stuff
directly from [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to 3.js JSON format.
And we still have to do the
animation and everything.
We have mainly static,
and scene stuff.
But to me, you need to get used
to Blender, but once you
get that down, it's easier.
For me, it works pretty
well as a pipeline.
MICHAEL ENSMINGER: Yeah, it was
the pipeline we used for
Rome, and it worked
pretty well.
RICARDO CABELLO: Yes!
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: I did some
Blender scripting, and the
nice thing about that is that
it's actually pretty simple to
get started and to just export
your objects and data from
Blender in whatever format
you want in your WebGL
application.
So that was great.
And you also get Bones, which
are sometimes a little fiddly
to work with, but it's
definitely doable.
RICARDO CABELLO: I
need [? Tree. ?]
[? Tree. ?]
PETE: What are some of your
favorite WebGL sites and demos
that you guys have seen?
BRANDON JONES: glsl.hiroku.org
or .com?
Ricardo, your little
shader toy?
I love that.
I love it so much.
RICARDO CABELLO: It's a
really interesting--
It's like this holds to a lot
of graphics developers that
they don't like JavaScript at
all, so that website is just
like something that they can put
their [? brain ?] out and
share what they know without
having to care about the
JavaScript.
And there's some really
crazy stuff on there.
I don't even understand half of
what the people are doing.
JEROME ETIENNE: Maybe a good
time to show some now?
Can you show some?
Some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
RICARDO CABELLO: Let me see.
PETE: So you can try screen
sharing if you'd like, and we
can see if that will work.
RICARDO CABELLO:
I'm trying it.
BRENDAN KENNY: Don't break it.
RICARDO CABELLO:
Is it working?
BRANDON JONES: Yes, yes.
BRENDAN KENNY: Pete might need
to select from screen.
PETE: I've got it forced on you,
so you're up on screen.
RICARDO CABELLO: See
about this one.
Well, I don't check
it too often.
So these guys, basically, this
website, this effect that we
are seeing here, it's
done with this code.
There's no textures or anything
being loaded.
It's just some code that
generates the textures
dynamically, and even the camera
path and everything.
So you can get stuff like
from this landscape.
Again, I have no idea how
to start to do this.
Let's see.
JEROME ETIENNE: Ricardo,
how large is the
code for those mountains?
RICARDO CABELLO: Can
you say it again?
JEROME ETIENNE: How many lines
for the mountains?
RICARDO CABELLO: Let me see.
JEROME ETIENNE: Because I
think that's a key point
[INAUDIBLE].
RICARDO CABELLO: 263.
JEROME ETIENNE: Yeah, pretty
good for what we see on the
screen, I would say.
RICARDO CABELLO: Yeah, and
there's like so many random
things, like this guy wanted
to have a lot of effects at
the same time.
I don't know.
Maybe it's a little bit too
small what they're showing.
Let me see if I can
find another one.
The good thing with this website
is that anyone--
oh, this one doesn't work--
is able to fork a really
working effect.
So someone will make like a
sphere or some simple ray
tracing effect, and then someone
else, like you don't
even know who they are, they
will come and they will
improve it.
There's a lot of knowledge
sharing from there, that I
find it very interesting.
I don't know, like really
crazy things,
like fractal stuff.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: I remember
seeing that some guy actually
implemented a snake game
using a fragment.
RICARDO CABELLO: There was this
challenge that because
there are two layers of data,
you can save some states of
the game as colored pixels
on the second layer
that you don't see.
So some people started
to try to create
games using that technique.
The website is a little
bit hard to navigate.
BRANDON JONES: You need
a search function.
RICARDO CABELLO: Yeah,
and tagging,
I guess, and comments.
Maybe someday it will come.
BRANDON JONES: There it was.
RICARDO CABELLO: Which one?
BRANDON JONES: Snake.
It's in the bottom corner
of the screen right now.
RICARDO CABELLO: Maybe it
was in the previous one.
I don't know.
I'm certainly not finding it.
BRANDON JONES: It should be
mentioned, I guess for anybody
who's watching this and not
entirely familiar with the
WebGL concepts, everything on
this particular site is more
or less done entirely
in shader code.
So that is somewhat limiting to
what can be done, although,
obviously, you've got a lot of
people here who are more than
happy to prove that wrong.
But it's not something that's
going to give you access to
the full range of WebGL
capabilities.
But it does provide a
fascinating look into what can
be done just with that
GLSL language.
RICARDO CABELLO: So I don't know
if it's working at all.
So basically, to make it
a little bit simpler to
understand, what we're seeing
here is just two polygons on
this screen, like one polygon
on one [? tangle ?]
that goes on the top left,
and one polygon on one
[? tangle ?] that goes
on the bottom left.
And the rest is just done with
this fragment shader, which
basically is this code that is
going to be executed for every
pixel that we see
on the screen.
And we have the position of--
I don't know whether you can see
any of that-- but from the
code, we have the position
where the pixel is.
From there, we can start to
have some mathematical
functions that will create some
shapes or some whatever.
It's up to you what you can
do with that information.
JEROME ETIENNE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
RICARDO CABELLO: For the game?
Yeah.
PETE: Cool.
Well, we're almost
at our time.
I want to just sort of open it
up to all of our guests and
say, is there anything you guys
want to add sort of as we
get ready to wrap
things up today?
BRENDAN KENNY: I wanted to add
that I know at least a few of
us are on Stack Overflow
and we watch
the WebGL tag closely.
So if you have any questions
about WebGL,
definitely get on there.
Make sure it's a technical
question, it's not like, what
should I do, and that's it.
It should actually be a specific
question, something
that you're facing.
But if [INAUDIBLE], there's
people that will answer.
BRANDON JONES: If you have an
urge to go on Stack Overflow
and ask, what's the best
WebGL framework?
Please don't.
That's been asked many,
many times.
But we're more than happy to
help with technical questions,
optimization questions, whatever
the case may be.
BRENDAN KENNY: This is broken,
why is it broken?
We're definitely
happy to help.
PAUL LEWIS: That question comes
up quite a lot, right,
when you're working
with WebGL?
This is broken.
Why is it broken?
I've just got a black screen.
BRANDON JONES: Exactly.
RICARDO CABELLO: Do you all
have a light machine?
BRANDON JONES: Is your camera
facing the right way?
JEROME ETIENNE: But my tricks
is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PETE: Cool.
All right, guys.
Well, we're at our time.
I want to say thanks everybody
for joining us today.
I hope you all found
it really useful.
Please add the Chrome Developers
Plus page to your
circles if you haven't done
that already, or +1 us.
Thanks to all our attendees and
speakers, and everybody
for watching.
Bye, guys.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Bye.
Thank you.
ILMARI HEIKKINEN: Bye bye.